Democratic Party has finally finished
its long-awaited probe of the deputy
chairman of the DNC Keith Ellison its
law firm says the allegations against
Allison can't be substantiated because
the accuser doesn't have videotape so
they're ignoring her word that would be
called victim shaming under other
circumstances Karen Housley is a state
senator a Republican US Senate candidate
from Minnesota and she joins us tonight
Karen are you happy with this new
standard that the DNC has articulated no
way thank you so much for having me
Tucker it just shows the hypocrisy of
the Democrat Party and the double
standard that they do have I'm running
for the hashtag me to Al Franken seat
for the US Senate in Minnesota and my
opponent is still out there campaigning
with them and she says that Keith Alex
Ellis and categorically denies these
allegations therefore she believes them
and she stands with them yet when it's
Brett Kavanaugh or Republican they want
a full and complete investigations so it
just shows the hypocrisy it's that and
the investigation that was done was done
of Keith Ellison who was the vice chair
of the DNC party done by the law firm of
a Democrat of the Democrat Party in
Minnesota so it's like the Fox watching
the henhouse so it is Karen Monahan the
Keith Ellison's former girlfriend she's
out on Twitter again tonight and I've
retweeted it she's she's begging for
somebody to listen to her but the
Democrats and the complete hypocrisy
that they are that they are aren't
listening to her so I look I have no
idea if the allegations are correct or
not I really don't know and I would
withhold judgment because I think that's
what fair people would do but I'm
surprised by the reaction have the press
in Minnesota the paper there in the Twin
Cities for example been hounding keith
Ellison to explain what exactly this is
about no absolutely not it is dead
silence among the media and the
Democrats in Minnesota yet all we hear
about is Brett Brett Kavanaugh and how
we should have a full FBI investigation
but the media is quiet and my opponent
Tina Smith again out there fully
campaigning and supporting keith Ellison
and nobody nobody is bringing these
accusations or calling for and the best
investigation so I did today I called on
the Attorney General of Minnesota to do
a full investigation of key
Ellison because the voters of Minnesota
they want to know before they go to the
polls in November
who is keith Ellison and he has he
really done these things to his
girlfriend but I I mean I can't keep up
with what the rules are because they
changed so often but quickly aren't we
supposed to believe the woman I keep
hearing that you know I sexual
harassment abuse domestic abuse it is
all wrong and every accuser should be
heard because and against keith ellison
these are some really really serious
accusation nobody is listening nobody is
listening to it's only about him so i am
i'm karen ethically about power and it's
yeah Thank You Tucker ash way more time
great to see you thank you very much